all right so
we're very happy to have amsa bastani
from
warton at upenn who is gonna tell us
about
how to use bandit for covid19 testing
sounds exciting thank you guys for
having me
uh to all the organizers and uh thank
you guys for attending this talk
uh yeah i'm very excited to talk about
some work we've been doing in
collaboration with the greek government
uh for a large scale banded
implementation for
um targeted copy thinking testing uh
this is joint work with uh kimon
dracopulos and vishal gupta from usc
uh john blacio giannis who is our
software architect as well as a host of
people from
the greek kovic 19 task force that i'll
mention at the end
um so just to kind of frame the problem
i want to give two or three slides about
the background before i jump into the
algorithmic design side of things
um so greece had a pretty tough time as
many tourist hotspot uh countries uh
when the pandemic hit at the start of
the summer
uh because they basically had to balance
keeping economic activity
uh by allowing international visitors to
come into the country
versus managing the spread of the
infection during this pandemic
and so two specific policy levers that
we'll be looking at
are targeted testing so ideally every
time a passenger or a visitor comes into
the country
we'll test them for covid and then if
they test positive we'll ask them to
quarantine
uh but unfortunately we just didn't have
the testing capacity to do this
uh so instead one option is instead to
just go and selectively test passengers
that we think
are very risky and most likely to test
positive and then
ask those people to quarantine if they
test positive
so this will naturally be a sort of
bandit problem uh and as a consequence
of the kind of exploration that's baked
into bandits
uh we have the ability to basically
maintain surveillance
over different countries so if a certain
location starts looking
you know very risky instead of wasting
all of our tests on them
and taking on the extra risk of these
infections potentially penetrating into
the country
we can actually make a policy decision
to re-list a country
and that means for every passenger
that's going to come in from there
will actually require a negative pcr
pretest within 48 hours
and obviously this is a big political
decision it will affect their arrivals
as well as the risk of people are coming
in
and these estimates basically inform
those decisions we've managed to
graylist
10 countries over the course of this
summer but i'll mainly be talking about
the first piece and a couple of
disclaimers so this is a data-driven
solution to allocate limited testing
resources
our goals are just to recommend who to
test we have very high compliance um
almost everyone we ask the test does get
tested
um and then uh identify hot spots to
inform which countries are going to get
gray listed
and offer interoperable insights to the
greek government what we are not doing
is we're definitely not identifying all
infected passengers there's no
machine learning algorithm that's going
to let you do that if you want to
identify all infected passengers you
just have to test everyone
uh and we're also not optimizing for
downstream contact tracing
some of the information we're collecting
gets passed on to them but we're not
um optimizing for that in this decision
making process
okay so uh without further ado here's uh
sort of how the system works uh so we
have about 30 to 100 000 passengers who
come into greece every single day
throughout the course of the summer uh
they can arrive in
41 different points of entry so by water
by land or by air
uh 24 hours prior to travel each
passenger will fill out a passenger
locator form
which uh basically or each family sorry
which basically reports uh where they're
coming from
various demographics and contact
information and so on
the main feature of interest here for
maintaining our risk scores will be the
origin
so basically the country or the city
that they're coming from usually
informs us on how likely they are to
test positive under a coveted test
and this all goes into our platform
which we've called ava
and most of these people unfortunately
will not get tested because we have
limited testing resources
so they'll just go into the country and
kind of enjoy their vacation
six to eight thousand of these people
based on our recommendations will
actually get tested
um and the way that works is you step
behind one of these currents at the
airport this is a real picture
and then you get a qr code and it's
scanned and it's linked to your sample
with your passenger locator information
and then your swabs get sent to a lab um
and then that information 48 hours later
will actually get the lab testing
results
uh which will feed back into our system
so naturally
uh by dynamically updating our risk
scores using the most
current testing results uh we can
maintain sort of the most
updated um uh risk scores and keep tabs
of how the pandemic is sort of evolving
in different locations
uh and use that to inform the next set
of testing
allocations so this naturally has
abandoned flavor because we have banded
feedback
um you can't actually observe whether or
not someone is positive
unless you actually test them right
okay if there are any questions please
just interrupt me um
so here there's a clear exploration
exploitation tradeoff
on one hand you want to test enough
passengers from every arm
so here when i'm talking about an arm
i'm talking about a location
so either a city or a country uh more on
that later
uh but just think of an arm as a set of
passengers from a certain location
um and then we want to make sure we're
basically pulling in
enough arms uh sorry we're testing
enough passengers from each arm so that
we can estimate whether whether that
particular location is very risky
and this basically will help us keep
tabs as a pandemic
uh but ultimately what we're really
interested in is the exploitation part
right so using these estimates
actually test survivals from risky arms
so that we can ultimately quarantine the
most positive cases
um so that the number of positive cases
that are kind of slipping under the door
into the country without quarantine is
as limited as possible so we can kind of
limit the spread of the pandemic
okay um so let me first talk about the
algorithm design in terms of test
allocation and then i'll describe some
of the statistical challenges that show
up in maintaining estimates for each arm
or how we even define these arms so
now that we've kind of framed this as a
multi-arm banded algorithm problem
um there you can basically use any
banded algorithm that you want you can
use thousand sampling or anything
we decided to use the optimistic
guidance index that was proposed by
gluten and furious with a one-step
lookahead window um so basically what
this does is it computes a
an optimistic guidance index that kind
of balances an exploitation and an
exploration term so here just for
notation
y is our prior so we're actually
maintaining uh bayesian estimates of the
risk for each arm
r is a binary reward so for every arm
when we pull it and we test the
passenger we get binary feedback like
either they tested positive or negative
um gamma is a discount factor so this
first term here
expectation of ry is just the estimated
prevalence
of that arm of passengers from that arm
so that's our exploitation term we want
to test
places that have high prevalence uh and
then we have an exploration term that
kind of captures the uncertainty in our
estimates
uh to make sure that these estimates are
actually good right
um so i'll refer details to that paper
but if you use this algorithm it's very
simple
all you do is for every arm you compute
this optimistic guidance index and then
you pull the arm that has the highest
index
uh you observe the feedback and then you
update your prior
and based on the observed reward or
feedback
so a couple very salient challenges in
this context that made this sort of an
approach very challenging
was first of all we have highly
non-stationary dynamics
um so the epidemiologist basically told
us any testing results that you
collected that are more than two weeks
old
are basically useless because if a
location was safe two weeks ago it
doesn't mean it's safe now
if it was risky two weeks ago it doesn't
mean that um it's risky now
uh so people kind of looked at the
non-stationary bandit literature and
they're sort of this forgetting
principle right
so basically what we did was a very
simple strategy we're just maintaining a
two-week rolling horizon for our
training data
so we don't use any testing results that
are more than two weeks old
um the more big uh the sort of bigger
challenge was that we also have a batch
decision making setting
so we don't get to dynamically decide
who we want to test during the course of
a day
we basically get the passenger manifest
at the start of the day and we have to
make all of our testing allocation
decisions
um and then those are uh conducted at
the airport
even if we did get um to dynamically
update it wasn't this bad setting we
would have another challenge which is
that we have delayed feedback
so once we decide to test someone we
obviously don't get feedback from them
until up to 48 hours later
which means that even if we weren't
dynamically making updates we wouldn't
actually
get to see the test results uh within
the same
uh when we go from one passenger to the
next
and you might think okay 48 hours one
day that's like three days that's not a
very long length of time
but actually three days is very long
given that our trading data is only
useful for two weeks and it expires
outside of that
um so that means that any exploration
that you're doing is only very valid
sort of for
11 day window which is not that long uh
and finally we have
port specific constraints so every port
of entry
has a different arrival makes from
different arms and different testing
budgets
um which introduces a unique set of
challenges
so let me first talk about the batch
decision making so if you were to
naively go ahead and implement this
optimistic git and syntax algorithm so
here's what would happen
so i have four arms here i've computed
the optimistic guidance indices
um arm one looks the riskiest so i'm
going to allocate a test to a passenger
from that location
but then of course i don't get any
updates because
um i'm not going to actually uh get any
updates until three days later
right so what would i do if i were to
naively do this i would just keep on
exploring arm one while we're waiting
for the testing results
which is clearly a very stupid strategy
because i'll just pull a ton of people
from arm one i'll under explore all the
other arms okay
uh and this is really bad again because
three days is a long time
because the data is only useful in a
sort of 14-day window
so people have recognized this there's a
big literature on batch bandits so this
problem
turns out shows up in platforms all the
time um and so
i think a lot of the literature kind of
follows an explore than commit type
strategy
so they have sort of early exploration
batches where they uniformly experiment
across all your arms
and they form good estimates and then
later batches just exploit based on that
information so
this unfortunately does not work in a
highly non-stationary environment
because our old exploration batches
quickly get discarded
right um so anything that we do any
exploration that we're doing on day one
is only going to be valid for about that
11 day window and then we have a rolling
window
uh and so splitting batches up into
exploration batches and exploitation
batches is not a good strategy in this
context
what we really need to do is to weave in
exploration
and exploitation within the same patch
so that we're constantly maintaining
this trade-off
as we you know gracefully roll our
training data set
so how do you actually do this if you're
not getting any updates uh what we did
was uh we
used certainty equivalent updates so
what we do is we simulate the expected
reduction in uncertainty from a test
uh for a given arm so let's say that
we've given a test to arm i and our
bayesian prior for that arm is say beta
alpha i beta i so alpha is the number of
successes and beta is the number of
failures
uh once we give it a test we're just
going to add the
mean number of successes that we're
expecting and the mean number of
failures that we're expecting for that
one test
to our successes and failures okay so
basically this will have the effect of
maintaining the same mean
uh but reducing the variance as a
function of the number of tests that
we've allocated
okay and i'm going to call this a pseudo
kittens index to kind of distinguish
from like actual kids indices
and these will naturally dynamically
update within the batch even though
we're getting no feedback at all
so what does this look like if we go
back to the same picture um
if i have arm one and i pull arm one um
once i actually allocate a test even
though i actually haven't gotten
feedback on that test
i'm going to do a certainty equivalent
update which will then give me
a new guidance index a pseudo given
syntax for that arm lambda one prime
which will be smaller because um it has
the same mean but it actually has a
lower variance
right um and so you keep doing this and
eventually
so uh for my next test now we see that
lambda 3 has the guy at highest index
and so we'll actually change around our
allocations
during the course of the batch as a
function of these pseudo-kittens indices
so i think this algorithm is pretty nice
because um it's very adaptive
to the uncertainty of each arm so
essentially what it does is for every
arm
in the exploration phase it allocates
the estimated number of tests that you
might require
to resolve the uncertainty for those
arms with high variance
so if you have a harm with very high
variance it'll get allocated a bunch of
tests to resolve that but if you have a
harm with low variance
it won't get as many exploration samples
which is nice
and then all the remaining tests get
allocated to arms with high mean reward
because obviously the first term of the
guinness index is the exploitation term
so if you have a high mean um you'll end
up getting
uh tested towards the end of the batch
so let's look at this on actual data so
again this is um
actual allocations and arrivals data um
from
our system uh for a given day so within
one batch
um so let me just explain this plot a
little bit on the x-axis we have the
different arms so again like arms are
locations so they might be country or
city identities uh
and here i rank them based on the risk
level so again this is computed in an
empirical base way that i'll
describe at the end but uh arms towards
the left side are very high risk and
arms towards the
right side are pretty low risk and on
the y-axis what we have are the number
of arrivals
uh for that given day so this obviously
changes throughout the course of the
summer
uh but this was what happened then and
you can see that the teal
uh bars are basically the number of
people from that arm that we
have recommended to test and the pink
people are kind of the people that we've
not recommended to test
uh and you can see that this algorithm
has this very nice benefit which is
exactly what you'd expect so it's easy
to explain to policy makers
on the left side you see that pretty
much everybody is getting tested so
that's exploitation because these are
high risk arms we want to make sure
we're testing all of them
uh if not you know people will be very
worried but you see that pretty much
every arm has a non-zero number of tests
being allocated even in the low risk
category
because you want to basically make sure
that you're doing exploration and
surveillance throughout the course
of the summer okay
um you might look at it is it that there
is such a big difference in the
right most two bars these two
perfect i was just gonna get into that
great question uh so the last bar looks
a little weird because i basically said
it's the lowest risk arm
and yet we're testing almost everybody
from that location which is weird
because um
presumably you'd want to test only a
small number of people for exploration
and this gets me to my next point which
is that we have port specific
testing constraints so some ports only
get arrivals from certain arms so people
coming in from the land border for
example only come from certain countries
um and they have testing budgets that
are determined by the labs that they're
contracting with
so the exploration exploitation tradeoff
is actually pretty different as a
function of the port
right um so let me jump into that given
that introduction thank you
um so the algorithm basically chooses
the arm with the highest pseudo index
and then finds the passenger
on the passenger manifested test but
passengers are coming at different ports
and passengers from some arms again are
only traveling to certain ports and then
again like i said some ports based on
their contracting
have very limited testing capacity which
creates this weird
um consequence that you might actually
want to save
tests at certain ports or unique arms
that will show up there
uh and there's been some work on bandits
uh with constraints by shipra and others
but it was it's still unclear how to
sort of merge this with our
batching procedure um so what we did was
just a simple greedy heuristic
so whenever we wanted to test the
passenger from arm i
we chose a visitor at the port that had
the most remaining tests available
so basically we would preferentially
test that less constrained ports
in the hope that we can save tests for
unique arms and very constrained ports
so just to summarize let me show how the
full algorithm works
so at the start of every day we get the
passenger manifest we get the port
specific testing constraints
historical testing results for every arm
the historical testing results we then
use to form empirical base estimates
compute the optimistic ins index we do
the certainty equivalent updates for any
pending test from the last two days
uh which will give us our pseudogins
indices and then we get basically two
tables right
so on the left side i have different
arms and i have their pseudo kittens
indices
and on the right side i have the
passenger manifest so i see different
arms passenger ids
which port they're expected to come into
and how many remaining tests are in that
port
so what i'll do is first i'll say okay
i'm greedy so i'll just say okay arm two
has the highest pseudogins index
give me all the remaining untested
passengers from arm two so we see
there's one coming into port one and one
coming into four
three port one has a lot of tests so i'm
gonna greedily pick
port one and i'm going to test this guy
so i scratch him off the passenger
manifest
and i do um my certainty equivalent
update uh so now arm two pseudo gains
index has gone down
and now arm one is the riskiest uh and
you can see that arm one uh that guy is
only showing up at four
three so you know good thing i saved my
test um
for this guy instead of the guy from arm
two right
and then it perceives like so on
any questions about the algorithm
i don't think it adds anything what i'm
gonna say but i was just wondering
can we think of the different portal as
like different players
playing the same military mandates and
they each have like different arms that
are open to them
um possibly i actually have not thought
about that
um right i think the challenge is that
this uh the challenge that we faced with
trying to solve some sort of
optimization problem across the ports
was that the pseudoguidance indices are
being updated
in the course of this as we allocate the
test and that's not closed form
um so we basically struggled with
integrating the lp with that updating
procedure
but probably you could do something that
incorporates optimization directly
okay um i wanted to mention two more
challenges in this context which is uh
estimating the prevalence for each arm
so one
really big problem with covid in general
is that the data is extremely imbalanced
so in most countries or locations only
one in a thousand passengers is going to
test positive
so this is a 0.1 percent um rate
and these are kind of the safe locations
uh and what we want to do is amongst all
of this hey we want to find the needles
which are
one percent uh positive prevalence
locations
so if you have about a 10 times rate
then that's what we qualify as a risky
location
if you're anything more than that like
the us for example then you just get
blacklisted and they don't allow you
into the eu anymore
um so that's one issue and then the
other issue is how you even define the
arms so i've just been dancing around
between city versus country
but obviously as you define it in a
coarser setting like a country level you
incorporate less variance because you'll
have more
observations for arm but if you have a
finer level like the city level
then you're going to incorporate um less
bias but more variance
and so there's a bias variance trade-off
to be solved here
so um for the first challenge what we
did was we took an empirical bayesian
approach so we're modeling every arm's
test results as a bernoulli
because it's a binary um binary feedback
and to do some sort of information
sharing across
arms to help us reduce variance we
assume that every pi
is sampled from a shared feature
dependent prior
which we chose the conjugate
distribution which is beta distribution
and the parameters of this beta
distribution depend on whether the
country is a white-listed country or a
gray-listed country essentially
um and this is kind of what our results
again this is actual data this is what
our results look like and this feeds
directly into the prime minister's
dashboard
uh recall again that we're discarding
any data that's over two weeks old
uh but on the x-axis again we have all
the different arms so these are country
or city identities
um and we have uh and they're ranked by
risk right so you can see that our mean
ev estimates so uh are decreasing
so the red points are the uh expected ev
estimate and then the dashed lines the
confidence intervals give you the 95
confidence intervals and you can see
that most locations look pretty safe
and then on the right uh on the left
side we have a sharp kind of
uptick where we see a couple arms that
are
starting to look very risky and these
are the people that we try to go out of
the way to exploit
um and you can see that we actually get
pretty decent control over these
confidence intervals even though this
data is so imbalanced partly by using
this sort of empirical evasion approach
okay so how do we deal with arm
granularity
so there's only about 100 relevant
countries that matter
um so if you define your arms as a
function of countries
uh then you get low variance because we
get a lot of samples
but you might get high bias because
there might be some cities that look
very risky
uh even after conditioning on the
country that that city is in
um but then you have thousands of cities
so there's no way you can allocate
hundreds of tests to each city so that's
going to pick up high variance
so what we do to deal with this is we
define most of our arms at the country
level
but we try to identify some very risky
cities that are risky beyond
their country level risk so what does
that mean
we basically use lasso regression to
identify a sparse subset of cities
that are particularly risky beyond
conditioning on their country's eb
prevalence um so just to kind of
visualize this let's say that this box
is one country
can i just ask you a quick question um i
mean
here's a set of arms is literally a
magic space
i mean it's actual places
on on the map so so we can i mean there
has been a lot of work on exactly trying
to
you know attack this bias variance
trade-off as to whether you want to
define you know
what what kind of size do you define for
your arms so i was just wondering so i
understand my maybe my question is very
theoretical and you're trying to do
something real so maybe that's where
there is a gap but
there are all those multi-scale type of
approach where
if you have a place where you don't have
many samples from then you want to have
a big arm
and if you have a place where you have
more samples and you can zoom in more
have you thought about using these
techniques i think that's the same thing
that the lasso regression does
um okay because basically it's trying to
identify places that you want to zoom
into if you have enough samples that it
looks
sufficiently more risky um
i think uh we basically embedded it into
a feature space that we thought made
sense
um there are sort of these
non-parametric zooming algorithms like
you were saying
uh we didn't find the geographic so you
can also think about these things lying
on a plane
and you have the geographic distances
between them that actually is not at all
informative for covid because um
like two places might be close by and
they might have urban versus rural
they might be mass compliers versus not
max
mass complying populations so we didn't
use that because it actually just wasn't
informative
but the zooming is basically what the
lasso is doing
well great thanks all right um so i
guess
jumping off of that so imagine that you
have um
seven different cities in a country um
and these numbers basically represent
what we think are current uh empirical
based prevalence estimates in these
locations
so you can see that six of these cities
kind of hover around two
and one of these cities looks very high
and it like looks around like a five
then what the lasso will do is basically
it will group together the six cities
um that have similar prevalences um so
you'll get one arm that's basically that
whole country
and then you'll get another arm which is
that country minus that very risky city
which has a prevalence of five uh and
this is very important because
for the bandit like when you're
targeting uh this whole country as a
whole might not look very risky but that
particular country is something that you
probably want to test everyone
that's coming in and then over time as
we get more samples and as we are
discarding samples we will update these
um arm definitions as we're sort of
zooming in and out
right because this is a non-stationary
problem you can't just zoom in you also
have to
zoom out sometimes as you kind of lose
samples over time
okay any questions about the algorithm
before i jump into the evaluation
awesome uh okay so a lot of people
obviously asked us okay so you did this
very complicated bandit thing like was
it actually
more useful compared to a random policy
that would just
test random passengers uh so we did this
using uh
we kind of did this evaluation using off
policy evaluation
with doubly robust estimation by dude al
um and we found that we got about 80
percent more positive cases than a
random policy
so this number might still change
because we're still actually running the
system right now
uh but that seemed like a pretty decent
lift but we actually think this is a
pretty significant underestimate
because one of the things that we did
throughout the course of the summer
is every time we saw a country basically
spike
um we provided visibility to gray list
that country
so what is gray listing again it's uh
when we ask it's a policy decision where
we would basically ask all passengers
from their country
to produce a negative pre-pcr uh test
before they can actually come in
so this is what happens so this is a
particular country that i can't name
that was great listed uh on that blue
dash line
so kind of early august and you can see
that their prevalence was pretty high
until they got gray listed and then
obviously after they got gray listed it
dropped a lot
because now you can only enter if you
have a negative pre-pcr test so you're
much less likely to actually test
positive
even then some people test positive
anyway because there's differences in um
testing accuracy and so on um the other
unfortunate consequence is that the
arrivals goes down right so a lot of
people turns out don't really want to go
get a test
it's difficult to get a test and so they
might have to cancel their trip
or they might test positive and so
that's a big um
friction for people coming in so this
part of the counter factual is a little
bit harder to estimate
because we don't really know what the
prevalence would have been for a long
time after the great listing decision
and what the arrivals would have been
but 80 is probably a significant
underestimate because both of these
things are in play um other benefits are
obviously you know you have a dashboard
i think every government right now has a
dashboard in the pandemic which helps
solve various operational problems like
determining the poor testing budgets
identifying bottlenecks and labs um like
i said uh
we briefly um helped out with the
contact tracing
and so we had discussions with the prime
minister the chief epidemiologist and
the kova task force every two days so
that's my co-author kimon
with the greek prime minister kiriakos
mitsutakis um
talking about this stuff um i'll just
say
one thing on public data a lot of people
have asked us why do you want to do this
complicated pipeline
when you could just use public kova 19
case or death data which is publicly
available in fact in most countries and
the european cdc
determine risk thresholds based on that
public data
we've actually found that public data is
super unreliable um
so here every point is a country and you
can see the prevalence based on our
greek uh our
greek labs on the x-axis and on the
y-axis you see the new cases reported
um publicly you can see that it's
the correlation is you'd be hard-pressed
to say the correlation is positive
even if it is positive it's extremely
noisy and this is because the testing
the public data suffers a number of
biases
uh it's also super delayed um so in the
red line we have the public data
estimates for a particular country and
in the green line we have our estimates
based on our lab results
and basically we can detect that a
country is spiking like about two weeks
before
it actually spikes in the public data
presumably because the patient has to
get
um has to get infected and then suffer
symptoms and get hospitalized before
that
data gets translated into the public
database whereas we see it right away
when we test them
so obviously if you don't have your own
in-house testing solution you're going
to be allowing a lot of people from that
country
inside and um at the by the time that
you actually catch it it'll be too late
because they'll have spread a bunch of
infections and then it'll be too late to
control it at the border
so all this to say we think you really
need in-house testing and this banded
policy seems to actually produce
a sizable lift compared to that um
yeah and i just wanted to quickly note
um there are a lot of people involved in
this project
uh my co-authors the kobit 19 ava
executive committee
as well as the covet 19 scientific task
force which involved
medical school people epidemiologists
and so on thank you
i think you're muted
thank you very much thanks a lot for the
talk
so i'm sure there are lots of questions
and probably people will want to have a
discussion on this topic
um so i think we should keep the
discussion to the discussion session
which is going to be after the next two
talk
but is there a question maybe on like a
very specific technical question
right now we can take one but again most
of the discussion will just have it
after the next two talks
okay if not uh thanks again amsa and
let's move to yonju uh yonjuk
are you here
yeah i'm here perfect